hello everyone and welcome back to the
semi-finals of the opera euro rapid we
are in the armageddon game so after
all of the four rapid games uh there
were two blizz games and the
both of the blizz game ended by white
player winning them magnus won the first
one and maxine won the second one and
now they have to play the armageddon
game
and for those of you who are new to the
chess world uh the armageddon game means
that
whoever plays with the black pieces uh
can get a draw and that means he wins
the match so uh or the player with the
white pieces
must win in order to win the match but
he does get one minute extra on his
clock and there is no time increment
uh prior to move 60. so that being said
uh let's check out this game magnus must
win this to win the match
uh or otherwise it's uh maximum vascular
graph in the finals so magnus with the
white pieces
opens with d4 and they will repeat their
line from the rapid section so knight to
f6
we have c for g6 uh knight to c3 and b5
the groomfield is on the board we have
captures captures and magnus yet again
goes for bishop to d2
uh we have bishop to g7 and only now e4
knight goes back to d6 as we've already
seen uh for the third time
bishop to e3 and castles we have a4
a5 so i'm pretty sure you remember this
uh
h3 and now knight to c6 uh we have
knight to f3 and
now comes the new move uh so maxim had
this especially prepared for this game
he pushes f5 and it's a very interesting
because this is a very very aggressive
approach
but maxine likes to play like this he's
not a very defensive player so
i i don't know i i i don't think uh
being black in armageddon uh works
all that much for him but uh we'll see
what happens so f5 by maxine
uh magnus captures on f5 bishop captures
on f5 and now
bishop to e2 magnus prepares the castle
to safety
and only now knight to be for preparing
c6 to gain
more control of the center here we have
rook to c1 as
knight to c2 was kind of a kind of a
threat
and now c6 by black we have castles by
magnus
and now knight six the d5 putting
pressure on the dark square bishop here
so magnus reluctant to part with his
bishop pair moves it
to b2 bishop to d2 and now queen to d6
developing the queen connecting rooks
and now rook to e1
and now uh magnus is a little bit um
cramped in as you can see all of his
pieces are here but um and maxine's
position is uh kind of
kind of open so it's gonna be very
interesting maxim starts with king to h8
he's expecting bishop to c4 so he
doesn't want his king to be on g8
and now knight captures on d5 here
uh you you could have improved the
position a little bit first maybe with
bishop to c4 or bishop to g5
but that this is armageddon you you
capture first and
ask questions later so knight captures
on d5
knight captures and now bishop to c4
so the bishop is uh activated this way
and this bishop is coming to g5
definitely at some point as the rook is
already
putting pressure along the e file so
knights the b4
uh and queen to b3 now again you could
start with bishop to g5 to go after the
pawn as the knight now moved and after
for example rook 88 go knight e5
with some threats of knight f7 check but
the knight can play knights to the five
the
defend is square and white is still
better with the idea of queen b3 and
the bishop can go after the a5 pawn but
it's all uh very
you know you don't want to spend too
much time so instead after night before
the immediate queen b4
uh and now rook 8 to d8 we have bishop
to g5 now putting pressure on this pawn
and now
bishop to f6 defending we have bishop to
h6 attacking the rook here bishop back
to g7
and now queen to e3 and now you can
capture here
uh but maxim doesn't like this uh he
doesn't want to party with his dark
square bishop this knight the g5 movie
is very scary the bishop controlling
this diagonal is very scary
so this uh the this f5 move the maxine
played uh
simply opened up a whole uh you know uh
sea of possibilities uh for for magnets
to attack
so here after queen to e3 we have rook d
the e8 defending the e pawn like this
and now bishop back to f4 attacking what
seems queen
knights the d5 counter attacking uh the
queen on e3
and here bishop captures on the e5 this
is the absol
the absolute best idea uh bishop
captures queen captures and now comes
rook to c5 uh improving the activity of
the rook pushing the queen back
queen to d8 and now comes the bishop to
e5 and this is a
pretty pretty crazy position because uh
there simply isn't a good move here for
black white is better however you put it
but the movement scene plays is the is a
pretty bad one and here
after bishop to c8 magnus is now
completely winning
and it's quite uh quite a beautiful move
so feel free to pause the video
and win this game for magnus while i
give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting such a
spectacular
idea now for those of you who found the
d5 that that is very nice but
there is an even greater move and that
is queen to h6
and uh here there is simply no good move
for black so the queen cannot be
captured because
just uh whoa bishop uh is spinning
the dark square bishop uh from black so
you have to play
something the problem is you cannot
capture the bishop because if the bishop
is captured
knight g5 and the queen is so far away
the queen cannot help out with the
defense
you're just getting checkmated to show
you how this is happening if you block
with rook f7 temporarily give up uh
the rook that's really pointless because
i mean your queen hangs but the white
doesn't even have to capture the queen
white can just continue like this knight
back to g5
and again threatens checkmate and even
if bishop here just
check king to here and just a queen
captures on g6 again threatening
checkmate
and after king g8 now you just go queen
f7 check king to h8 and knight to e6
and here you simply resign because this
is checkmate and also this will result
in checkmate
and you cannot defend against both
threats uh so after this bishop the c8
after this queen to h6 move uh capturing
not
not possible so maxine finds the only
move that continues the game which is
rook to f6
but here magnus very very happily grabs
that rook he wants to trade on he wants
to get
into an end game as quick as possible to
enjoy his extra material so he captures
an f6 he trades with
check real captures queen captures and
now queen back to e3 he offers a queen
trade now he's up material
and he's very happy to play this end
game so max team of course declines
and the queen back to e1 going after the
a5 pawn because there's no point in
guarding the d4 pawn if black captures
this is just checkmate
queen eight check bishop f8 queen
captures an f8 checkmate
so after queen to e1 bishop to f8
attacking the rook here and now rook
captures on a5
we have bishop to d7 maxine without
without an active move in sight we have
rook to a7 attacking the pawn here
queen to b8 and now queen to a5
threatening
rook a8 to pick up the bishop here after
the queen moves
uh so here after king to g7 still rook
to a8
now comes queen to f4 getting the queen
out of harm's way but
just queen to d8 now threatening to pick
up the bishop here
queen to c1 check king to h2 and queen
to f4 with
check but now uh magnus doesn't have to
play g3 magnus can just play king h1
which he does
and now point is after queen c1 check
you can just play knight g1
and there are no more checks black is
just getting destroyed here
uh as this is being threatened and you
don't really have a good move here once
because this bishop is under attack and
also this bishop
so instead after bishop the c1 check we
have king to h2
uh sorry after queen to f4 check we have
king to h1 and now queen goes back to d6
to guard this point
this bishop ended this bishop but now
just queen to b8 magnus offers a queen
trade and if the queen moves somewhere
uh well that doesn't guard the bishop
just queen captures and f8 is happening
and this will be checkmate
so queen to b4 maxine tries to keep an
eye on the bishop but here
magnus just played rook to a7 and it was
in this position on move 40 that
uh maxine rashel agrawal resigned the
game and magnus wins the armageddon game
which means
magnus goes into the finals to face uh
wesley so
as uh wesley wesley won his match
against steve mora javo we're also going
to show
some games from that match i'm probably
gonna gonna show that tomorrow
so really really well stuff magnus uh
with so many blunders manages to to to
win the match
it's simply crazy he he wandered a
bishop and he also blundered the queen
the one due to a blunder the the other
one was actually a mouse slip but still
incredible that he still manages to beat
maxine uh with so many
misfortunes happening to him in the
match uh but what are you gonna do those
are the
the joys of online chess it would seem
uh so here you resign because
there's really nothing to do uh rook
captures on b7 is happening there's no
stopping that
you can't really do anything here uh you
could move
move the king but then still just
captures the bishop is under attack and
uh
the point being that there's no attack
for you to even go for
and you're already down material so
maxim doesn't want to play this he
resigns
and magnus is off to the finals so
really crazy stuff again magnus crushes
uh maxine
uh in in the first match like he did do
move then maxine bounces back in the
second match and then magnus has to you
know uh
grasp for straws to to kind of remain in
the game and
you know nothing is going his way he's
blundering pieces back and forth
and then in the armageddon game uh
maxime goes for this crazy f5 line and
magnus just uh
crushes him but it was a uh it was uh
such a such a beautiful moment where
when this bishop to see it was played to
play this queen to h6
so you know really really amazing to
play this
uh with all of black's pieces on the
back rank is just uh
awesome stuff might even use this as a
thumbnail
uh so yeah that's the game and the the
the coverage of their semi-final match
hope you guys enjoyed it
uh i would like to thank no deathman uh
louis burkhart
david kimura harry lewin and stephen
hunt for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot to really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching
and i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the opera euro rapid
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day